[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Off the
coast of California,
scientists from
UC Santa Cruz are
scouring the ocean
for what they hope
is the key to
fighting a new breed
of drug-resistant superbugs.
BRYSON VOIRIN: So we're
out here in Monterey Bay
looking for the next potential
medical breakthrough.
But how are we going to do that?
ROGER LININGTON: So the
first thing we need to do
is make our scuba diver
collect the samples.
And so we're going to
take this ring down there.
And we're going to make
pairs of duplicate samples
during the dive in as
many discrete locations
as we can, and then
take these samples back
to the lab for workup.
BRIAN VOIRIN: And how
cold is the water?
ROGER LININGTON: Oh.
The water's 55.
BRIAN VOIRIN: You've
got a dry suit.
ROGER LININGTON:
I've got my dry suit.
You're wearing a wet suit.
We'll see how we fair.
So there hasn't been
a new antibiotic
developed in about 20 years.
And the rate of resistance
to existing antibiotics
in hospitals can run
upwards of 40% to 60%.
Given that it takes
about 15 years
to bring a drug to market,
there was a real pressing crisis
in the antibiotic
discovery arena.
NARRATOR: According to the CDC,
at least two million people
in the US become infected
with drug-resistant bacteria.
And at least 23,000
die each year
as a result of these infections.
BRYSON VOIRIN: I mean,
you say it's a crisis.
I mean, if you had to rate
it on a scale of 1 to 10,
where are we at on
the antibiotic crisis.
ROGER LININGTON: 11.
It's very serious.
We are about to return to
a pre-antibiotic era, where
even basic surgeries and
other medical procedures
can lead to death by septicemia
and other untreatable bacterial
pathogens.
NARRATOR: The history
of antibiotics
is relatively short.
In 1928, Scottish
scientist Alexander Fleming
discovered penicillin
capable of killing bacteria.
Scientists Howard
Florey and Ernst Chain
then mass-produced it in
time for use on Allied forces
during World War II,
the first example
in which more soldiers died
in battle than from infection.
It drastically changed the
world of modern medicine
and extended the average
human lifespan significantly.
Not many more antibiotics have
been developed since then.
BRYSON VOIRIN: Now, why has the
discovery of new antibiotics
kind of fallen by the wayside
in the past 30 or 40 years?
ROGER LININGTON:
Developing new antibiotics
is not the most effective
way to make a steady profit.
If you make a new drug
for asthma or diabetes,
that's a drug which patients
will take likely every day
for the rest of their lives.
So from an economic
perspective, drug companies
don't have much incentive to
develop new antibiotic drugs.
NARRATOR: As Fleming accepted
his Nobel Prize in 1945,
he warned that the misuse
and overuse of antibiotics
could result in
drug-resistant bacteria.
And he was right.
ROGER LININGTON: If you put
antibiotics into heavy use,
then eventually
bacteria will find a way
to become resistant
to those drugs.
If it hasn't been helped by
the poor use of antibiotics
for people with
flu-like symptoms,
if you have a viral infection,
antibiotics don't help.
And the more you
take antibiotics,
the more you are
helping to sort of build
that pool of resistant strains.
BRYSON VOIRIN: It's kind of
like the boy who cried wolf.
Like, if you cry
wolf all the time
and then we actually have a
wolf, then it doesn't work.
ROGER LININGTON: Right.
Exactly.
It's a combination of factors
that have led to this.
NARRATOR: Roger's team of divers
collect sand from the seafloor,
a relatively
understudy environment
for medical research,
but one that
is rich with unknown chemistry.
These scientists hope that
the microbes within the sand
will lead to new and powerful
drugs to fight bacteria.
However, the search
area is very large.
And it may take
years to determine
if these samples hold a cure.
BRYSON VOIRIN: So
let's see the samples.
ROGER LININGTON: OK.
So here we are.
So this is what we managed
to get on this dive.
Although they may look pretty
similar to the naked eye,
at the microbial level,
every one of these
is a completely
different population.
BRYSON VOIRIN: And it's
literally just sand.
ROGER LININGTON: It's just sand.
So this is very low impact
science on the environment,
but the potential
applications are huge.
So what happens next
is we'll take the sand,
put it on Petri
dishes, and allow
those microorganisms to grow.
And then, a microbiologist
will look at those
and select specific species
for study for their chemistry.
BRYSON VOIRIN: So this
could come from this.
ROGER LININGTON: Absolutely.
It's possible that the
microorganisms in this sample,
may one day make compounds which
we can add to tablets like this
to treat diseases.
BRYSON VOIRIN: The
cure to what we're
looking for could be anywhere,
in the ocean, in the mountains,
in the sky.
ROGER LININGTON: Right.
And if you tried to
do that discovery
in a random way, where you
went into the environment
and picked microorganisms
at random, you would fail.
There are many millions of
sequences that we have not yet
investigated.
Deciding how to do
that in an ordered way
is the challenge for the next
generation of natural product
scientists.
SPEAKER 1: This episode is
a part of Seeker Stories.
We're trying to bring you cool
stories from around the world.
But in order to do that,
you need to subscribe.
So please click on that button.
And thanks for watching.
NARRATOR: On another
episode of Seeker Stories.
SPEAKER 2: So this
woman is allowing us
to take pictures of the bears.
Here they are in their cages.
Hi.
So pretty.
So there is one, two, three,
four, five, right there.